foreign
check it out y'all ah Brooklyn's newly
opened Museum of failure oh celebrates
bad ideas silly designs and over hyped
products that's cool oh products too oh
that's cool is the HD DVD in there
you know what Blu-ray whooped its ass
not to brag but I was an early adopter
of HD DVD yeah that's not really a brag
is it no not really
um no dude because everyone was saying
oh porn's like you know if porn adopts
it then it's gonna make it and if you
remember at the time HD DVD was adopted
by porn and so everyone thought that's
the biggest gainer for H2 DVD nah but
then blue away why did blu-ray kick its
ass Sony just kept on delivering they
kept on signing other Studios to it and
it just comes down to the product and
the supply you know what I mean yep yeah
yeah damn this new Museum in Sunset Park
section of Brooklyn proves that even the
most successful businesses can have
terrible ideas and stuff like that it's
called Museum of failure a lot of
successful businesses oh yeah dude so
I'll talk about a couple things that are
in there and then of course we get to
Riff on what other things we think could
totally go organic formats we're just
like JK news anything
um so in 2011 for example there was Bic
for her pens anybody remember this wow
big for her do you remember this it was
solely development marketed to Target
women the only difference was that there
was glitter and a higher price tags that
was it stupid Oh I thought it would be
like better shape for hands or something
no it just had glitter on it like a nice
curve [__] already had pens dude yeah
and they're going to Sanrio anyways hey
do you guys all have the getting this
thing from the like writing a lot and
drawing in a lot like you know this this
right here like a callus that didn't go
away yeah like I feel like we all
developed this as writers you know the
new generation they don't have that all
right they got their typer so they have
it on their thumbs right here and here
yeah or they might even just have carpal
tunnel and [__] from being on their
phones do you have that they're gonna
get early onset we're gonna need cyborg
hands and [__] yeah that's kind of tired
that's gonna be thick yeah so there's
Google Glass if anybody remembers oh
yeah oh my God bro one of the funniest
things about Google Glass because I was
a tuber right and I still I guess I am
but they were doing prototypes for
Google Glass you got one no no but there
was people that I was around at all
times at Maker Studios who were like
walking in with Google Glass and like
they're trying to sell it but like you
they can tell you can tell they don't
really think it's that cool but it's
cool that they got one earlier yeah yeah
and that's all they had with it yeah
like so you're walking around YouTube
space La back in the day and people
Google Glass and it's like dude this
[__] [__] sucks what was the point of
it it was like oh dude like I'm using my
eyeball to like Google something right
now it's like dude that sucks like it
took it takes like four minutes for them
to Google something it's like you think
that that's cool like you're an early
adopter oh cool you got Google ass like
everyone thinks you suck dude
everything's you look weird that's how
people worry about Snapchat specs too
all right oh damn and then like Pokemon
Snap comes out like five years later
people using AR on the phone that's the
application right but yeah there was the
rejuvenate electric facial mask from
1999 a beauty product that shocks the
face with electrical stimulation I think
people still use stuff like that for
sure they do not remember that that
shit's probably gonna come back watch
the uh to make a younger face yeah
stimulate the nerves yeah definitely
someone's gonna do it there's the now
discontinued Segway Scooters yes Dean
Cayman that was oh yeah they were a
thing and then they're just gone
remember they had tours that was a dumb
invention because I had a lot of fun on
Segways Segways are tight but they're
gone it was pitched it was pitched as
like the big question mark right and it
was like gonna be the next flying
machine potentially and he was like
teasing it like it's the next innovation
of people moving and everyone was
expecting like you're gonna be floating
around and [__] and then like the Segway
came out and I was like that's it yeah
yeah I mean it's pretty lame it's
because the rent to cops use them and
that just made it like you want to
murder your product immediately yeah and
you look so dorky with a helmet and just
like a collar Segways do look stupid but
when you ride them they look fun
it was pure B2B right like you're
selling to businesses like or like
security for it yeah and like that's not
people moving like they just have tours
remember they would be like segments
yeah hell yeah dude I think that would
be cool but but it's difficult to make
those that shape look cool but now they
have the one wheel have you seen that
yeah it's it's this it's almost the same
technology unicycle but on a skateboard
you just stand on it and it's dude bird
scooters are more Innovative than
Segways yeah so they're more fun and
they're faster they're more they're more
compact what to do the electric scooter
you're like oh this is far better this
is way better I think when you're
standing this way it just feels cooler
than standing this oh for sure yeah
yep there was the uh massive set of
metal tip darts a long game that used to
be sold to kids but uh they just ended
up being weapons that people would throw
so just lawn darts yeah
that were metal tips you're just poking
holes in your grass yeah dads there was
a uh a strange looking hula chair which
was a machine which promised to give its
users abs while they would watch a movie
or do some work however when yeah I
remember they sold it a lot at the Asian
stores yeah but when when somebody said
yeah the problem is when when you sit
down on it uh it the the rocking and the
spinning was so intense that it would be
you couldn't focus on anything else so
that would just be just be like this the
whole time dude I just played PS5 VR you
ever play this oh is it sweet oh my God
she's like dope dude Horizons sick oh my
god dude so me and my buddy Chris Mormon
right he's the [__] poker guy he had
he just bought this [__] because he got
tilted after like losing a hand or
whatever and he's like I'm buying VR
[__] it and so he buys he buys his VR
[__] he's like Steve come play VR like
let's [__] let's get [__] up and
play VR so I was like all right so then
I go over this place and we're playing
VR and like I got this headset on and
[__] and I'm mountain climbing and my
brain is just completely tricked like it
looks it it looks like a game right but
you're so close to the surface it's like
come it's like I see this Cliffside I
know it's not here but my brain thinks
it's right here and I'm scared of it and
like I'm supposed to like you have these
two controllers like they're holding
like this so you keep keep on holding
the buttons so that you can climb so you
go back to that the climb you like that
and dude your brain is like I am
like I might my [__] heart went into
my stomach
I was like I am [__] 50 feet up even
though it looks like a game but it looks
like incredible and then it has me like
scaling side to side over like a
waterfall and like if I'm like 500 feet
in the air or some [__] it was scary as
[__] and I I got motion sickness after
like 25 minutes of this [__] damn that's
crazy but it's having you like oh [__]
there's a beast here you pull a bow out
with your left hand you [__] go like
this with your right hand and you fire
an arrow by letting go and it works this
[__] is so cool it's accurate it works
it's so sick this is fun how is the
comfort of it though honestly like it
was great if not for the motion sickness
of only the climbing stuff got to me the
rest of it was fine because that's the
hard part with like the the other like
the meadow ones and stuff like that at
the end of the day you still got this
giant [__] machine on your head that
like gets really intense you know what I
mean but dude it's the closest thing I
felt since like when we all got N64
played in 64 for the first time like
this is like the next thing wow I felt
the first time I played a VR it was so
crazy I went out made with like some
some family and we all played like a
round of VR and it was so crazy
afterwards where I was like I have to
get one of these and I did and then I
bought one and I was like all right I
had enough did you ever try the porn no
I haven't I would play the boxing though
maybe I'll try it today there was
notoriously no games for like a while
right except for beat saber or whatever
boxing game was this Horizon [__] is
like next level that's amazing that one
looks taupe yeah you know what else is
in here the DeLorean oh yeah that's a
massive failure
because it's just the only model and
then that's it
the failure yeah it's in the shop the
whole time it's a failure for the guy
who made it because he died not even
knowing how much of a cult classic it
would be but he was also a con artist
too was he yeah
do you ever watch the documentary about
him yeah but
he was uh he didn't actually get
convicted no he was misunderstood
and The Deloreans released by GMC DMC
DMC oh yeah so there's no other brand I
mean they don't have any other cars it's
the only one yeah but now they do now
they got these like new ones but they're
not net they're not technically
Deloreans they're just trying to revive
the brand isn't it like an electric
DeLorean or something yeah oh that
doesn't work it's kind of its own thing
but I still think there it's a success
in theory but not for the dude like not
for the reason he wanted it to be how
did Back to the Future get it get that
yeah
so the story is that it was going to be
a dish a washing machine is yeah it's
like a fridge or some [__] fridge or
some [__] and then um like I think it
was zemeckis or Bob Gale the writer saw
the DeLorean like that they're like that
looks like it yeah that's way better
than a washing machine a better cell
yeah it was originally going to be a
washing machine something like that
either that or a fridge looked like a
fridge yeah yeah yeah
oh like Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventures when they go in the food like
the phone booth want something that
everyone knew that like is like in your
home or like around you right so it's
relatable but then they didn't know how
they were gonna do it yet so you know
what you know you know in Indiana Jones
when when in Indiana Jones he like jumps
into a fridge to escape a blast yeah
yeah so one of their early Concepts was
that that's how Marty travels back in
time he jumps through this fridge to
escape this nuclear blast and it sends
it back in time wow yeah but that's like
you know that's not a cool classic I
also never get made because like a lot
of people don't realize that like for
people that love Deloreans they get that
news every year that this is gonna
happen and we've been seeing it for them
is cyber truck ever coming on I don't
know give up I kind of gave up you you
gave up your deposit or what it was only
100 bucks but
I would like to see it come out I think
it's such a cool why I think it's
lagging you think elon's too busy on
Twitter yeah you think he's just [__]
off on Twitter probably but it's been
like three years now yeah but this dude
busy fighting American corruption
American hegemony yeah yeah but the
DeLorean failed because it was
overpriced when it came out and it
didn't deliver on anything they said it
was gonna do like refrigerate food
well just in terms of like the
performance it was super underpowered
because it didn't meet all these
regulations so they had to down grade
everything on it and they still released
it so people were like where's my car I
paid all this money for and it was just
a piece of [__] and of course it breaks
all the time and the funniest thing
about the 88 miles an hour thing is it
could barely go 80. the speedometer 85.
so that means my Land Cruiser could beat
it uh easily yeah most cars most cars
can beat it has the engine of a station
wagon it's like not wow it's not like it
looks sexy yeah it's fun to drive pretty
slow dude there's a handling pretty good
no it's no power steering
whoa you got a three-point turn you end
up with freaking so fast arms and you
got people crowding you only reason why
you would get a DeLorean is because of
Back to the Future that's it that's or
or you like the story I guess of like
John's have you met any DeLorean
enthusiasts that don't really care about
Back to the Future No I not really well
Chad has one and we he has it signed by
Bob gay on the dash and by the the chick
who was the Jennifer in the first movie
she has like a suit store in in Studio
City and I told you guys we took it out
Valentine's Day to an arcade and when we
showed up every single dude there was
like we wanted to suck on a dick bro
like you guys are getting your dick
sucked by all these [__] nerds and
then we go and we go to the Pinball Hall
of Fame right and then when we're
leaving everyone's watching us leave and
we're like all right see you later nerds
and then we get in the car and like it
won't start it's like click click click
click and then all the Nerds are like so
excited because they get to help us push
startup and then it won't start and it's
Valentine's Day so then me and like
Nikki and um my buddy Chad's wife V they
had to pick us up to take us to dinner
for Valentine's Day and we had to leave
the car at the Pinball Hall of Fame and
figure it out later in the tow truck my
car would probably not work no no
exaggeration four to five times a year
it would just conk out for one reason or
another
wow that's a bad invention and then
there's little things there's like
things you just have to live with you're
like like oh okay sometimes the key just
won't turn if I gotta sit here card
wasn't on uh Back to the Future it would
have just been a fluke but it looks so
sexy it does stainless steel is awesome
yeah it's great and in the suicide door
yeah I mean you got enough people that
are putting electric motors in those you
don't need that one true and if you get
someone who's like super nerdy and they
do the the sound effect of the golden
door that like the back of the future
Gucci I'll pay for that I'll pay 35
grand for that yeah it is a fail here
[Music]
oh